was ist 12 geteilt durch 3 -4
richtig kann nur mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video von mir ich habe euch mal
wieder gesagt ihr sollte auf die website
oracle gehen und dort als innsbrucker
eingeben so dass wir miteinander video
chatten können und das mache ich heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine ewigkeit später am
das nicht mein name hey er auch bestens
haben wir uns nicht darüber gesehen ja
ich da gerade irgendwo hier kommst du
mir bekannt vor wittmann dass ich jetzt
eine neue facetime hab letztes mal als
ich das gemacht habe ich meine stadt
instagram an allen möglichen plattformen
bescheid gesagt dass heute ankommen dann
irgendwie die website abgestürzt
deswegen habe ich nur bei twitter
bescheid gesagt also dass es
wahrscheinlich noch total gewesen
ja aber erst 20 minuten
ja wir wissen aber einer anderen
perspektive als letztes mal oder
natürlich was geht dir heute noch am
sonntag
netflix man kennt hallo
tschüss
na ja mir geht es super wie geht es dir
was machst du so
ah ok hast du dein micro ausgemacht oder
irgendwie so
antworte jetzt einfach mit daumen hoch
oder daumen runter
sollten alle laser luca auf instagram
folgen
[Musik]
luca peter hass france von geldgeilen
luca shop.de
leiden [ __ ] glück warum war der als
helfer sollten
daumen runter ist ganz wichtig auch bei
meinen youtube videos immer
es geht heute noch so bei dir
ach komm hoch ja gut das stimmt wie alt
bis zu 5 555 555 5555 1
das daumen runter
ist auf jeden fall bisher der
beschissene gesprächspartner würde euch
da kann man so etwas nicht machen was
hast du dazu genau wer ist dein
lieblings youtuber
oh ja da kommen wir machen jetzt mal
eine matheaufgabe war als was ist 12
geteilt durch 3 -4
richtig dann würde ich sagen machen als
nächste aufgabe zweimal 68
zweimal 68
zweimal 6 -8 fassen wahrscheinlich sind
deine eltern nicht zufrieden
okay für dich die letzte matheaufgabe
jetzt was ist 17 3
das ist richtig ich werde erstmal
weitergehen zu einer nächsten person
aber wenn du noch irgend jemanden grüßen
möchtest hast du jetzt die chance dazu
menden
mandy
als man ihn deine freundin
ist mandy deine schwester
mandy dein handy
ok ja schöne grüße an die das handy gysi
gute qualität komfort zu machen
ja klar natürlich
immer wieder gern was geht bei dir
gerade so eigentlich hausaufgaben machen
warum bist du denn jetzt hier auf oracle
man was hast du denn auch bekommen von
der lehrerin sexual was französisch ich
war schon mal in frankreich warst du
schon mal in frankreich 29 paris ich
weiß einmal paris wir finden zu paris
wie findest du congo after das sind
meine lieblings jets wie geht's dir ja
blendend bei dir hängt wäsche im
hintergrund ich glaube ich musste noch
aufhalten also ich meine das beste
kleidungsstück hast du schon selbst
[Musik]
alles gleicher zeit drei wochen später
hallo ja alles von dir im ernst hast du
irgendwie zu viel geld oder auch das aus
hass mehr merchandise formiert sich das
kissen ich habe auch ganz viele kissen
erich seeger dass eine im hintergrund
daher krabbelt man hat einfach gefehlt
ja nee ich bin schon echt glaube ich
bitteschön nice
eine weiße wand hallo erstmal genießen
muss kotzen verständigen
was hast du denn für ein laptop ja ok
den kann es mir jetzt schlecht zeigen
wenn du bist so einen alten acht den
klar den kenne ich
hy-line ja doch ist ein dunkelfeld als
werden da will ich die keine lange
aufhalten
bitteschön ja klar logisch laser luca
haltern als cool schöne grüße seine
freundin von dir alter ist die korrekte
auf ok schöne grüße erstmal ganz laptop
umschmeißen da hat jemanden geilen
julian ich sehe schon
ich war gerade draußen und es waren null
grad und ich war im t shirt draußen das
war nicht so entspannt das heißt ich
glaube ich bin bald krank
danke für deinen daumen hoch der
mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend was machst du heute noch so
da ist nicht alter gerne plan möchtest
du einen foto machen oder so
danke danke wie lange bist du ja schon
hier auf der plattform hier seit drei
tagen jetzt weil er keine ahnung ich
sind dabei innerhalb krank bin jetzt
richtig kalt noch von draußen angucken
wo kommst du her wenn dieses hoch lade
habe ich leute aus augsburg hier
beschweren kann ich mich ja
normalerweise eher weniger
[Musik]
mann ich wollte so tun als welchen
standbild aber ich kann das nicht lassen
battle machen lasst uns mal ganz lange
die augen gucken bis einer lacht
ja ich glaube das kann noch jahre so
weitermachen das bringt gar nichts ja
klar direkt foto anstatt erst mal zu
begrüßen menschen nicht gesehen
ach so sie schon gemacht
ach so ja auch nicht so viel was geht
wo kommst du her sieben ja klar ja ich
war einmal eine autobahn herzlich selber
zeigte ein typ ja die ganze zeit seinen
fuß ebenfalls eine autobahn herren das
[Musik]
heruntergekommen hat oder leuchtelemente
taschenlampe das war allerdings auch vom
video meine damen und herren wie ich
schon gesagt habe werde ich ab jetzt
wirklich jedes wochenende mit euch auf
medien versuchen video chatten also mit
euch dann lagern dies leben bei euch und
wir vielleicht sein könnte wenn ihr das
ausbrechen würde aus eurem jetzigen
geistes und dann vielleicht
die joh